we are back
today i want to talk about one of the
best
reading experiences of my life which
started in
uh you know a normal way
how how how one does i i started hearing
about this hype train this hype train
was rolling fast
and it was chubby and it was a chugging
embodied
by the figure of brandon sanderson who
has become one of my favorite writers
and he seems like a really terrific
human i don't know how maybe through
daniel green's videos or some someone's
videos
i started hearing this positivity and
all this excitement
about this uh this [ __ ] guy he talks
a little bit like ben shapiro but um
basically every person on the internet
told me
not to start with the stormlight archive
it's too complex for your little
pea brain mine yeah well i said no
no not me i am i'm big brain okay
i can start with with the hardest [ __ ]
okay i've read moby [ __ ] dick
oh ooh start with mistborn i wanted to
start
with the big final boss the way of kings
how did that turn out for me
i hope to bring people
in to read the book and do it as i did
with no information
and way too much confidence
so there are two pieces of advice i got
from pretty much everyone around about
entering the way of kings and that was
be patient it's long and the second
thing was
brandon sanderson's prose is not
the best but he is an
excellent plotter and excellent with
character if there's if there's one
piece of advice i wish i could have
given myself before reading this book
that
nobody else gave me it was don't
analyze and re-read
every word and every and and hyper focus
on
every detail the information is going to
be given to you in a very comfortable
accessible way you don't really have to
hunt for clues you can i mean there are
intricate clues put in there but i wish
i could have told myself
just relax you know if there's stuff you
don't get the first time
it'll come back again i guess i'll get
the boring part out of the way real
quick
real quick even though you could find
that on
uh [ __ ] amazon you know what
never mind if you want to learn about
what this book is about
don't come watch my videos okay maybe
okay let me i'm being a little too
hostile and i don't understand why so
the book
follows three important characters and
what's hard about the story is that they
do not interact what's i won't say how
much but let's just say
most oh my god am i even is that a
spoiler i don't know
oh god this is stressful the characters
are
in different places just when
something's getting interesting
you jump to another character and you
start building up from there so it feels
very exhausting at some point and that's
what
made it really hard to get through i
just kept stopping and starting
i wasn't consistent i i never read a
fantasy book this this long i was
frustrated with the clues it felt like
they were just
all this information that was just there
and i was really starting to think this
is just going to be the whole book
and it's just this is it but
someone on the internet told me just
wait till you get to page
700. then things get really interesting
i waited i got to page 700 then i got to
page 800
you know page 900 though
oh yeah oh yeah have faith that the book
will follow through on the promises it's
made it's making
the book starts with one of the most
captivating
prologues i've ever read uh i thought it
was funny that people were complaining
about
sanderson's throws or his ability to
write beautiful prose because
i thought that evident in the prologue
the first few sentences that
he writes very clean very precise
and pretty in a way sentences and that
clarity
is really what you get what gets you
through a book of this magnitude with so
much world building
the next book in the series the stakes
are so much higher but for
the majority of this book the characters
are kind of
stuck you you really get to live in this
world
day by day you get to see each
character's problem
day by day dalinar's character for me in
this book was the least
engaging it seemed like he had the least
to do
i liked shalon even though her character
did not have
much going on either but i really liked
how she was
opening up and asking a lot of questions
and bringing new information to this
world
and of course kaladin is the standout
character in the way of kings
he is going through the kind of
suffering
few people could ever imagine
it's very slow i mean it's just it's
just slow
so i picked this up on and off for about
a year about halfway through i really
committed and was like you know what
let's just let's get through this come
on let's get to the end
and see what this [ __ ] is all about at
one point i paused reading
and picked up war and peace thinking
yeah i i need to get away from this book
and read something a little
faster like war and peace i actually
didn't read that much
of warren peace i read about like 130
pages my biggest complaint with the book
is yeah i i truly think that a lot of it
could have been
shortened i still recommend reading this
it's a hundred percent worth it it
really is worth the time it's worth the
energy
there are so many exciting
things exciting scenes the climax is
always talked about as being so
extraordinary because
it fulfills what you want in a way you
never
thought you'd want it if you're not used
to reading epic fantasy if you're not
used to brandon sanderson's style of
writing there are support groups out
there
reach out i guess this is less of a
review and recommendation than
like uh you can do it like just stick
through you can
you can read this that element of of
hugeness of amazing scale
there were action set pieces in this
book that are just
my god i i really wish that this series
is made into a tv series because
way of kings would be a perfect first
season of tv
wow it really feels like it's almost
written for television
oh look there's there's that there's
that face there's that winning smile
you finish the book and you you look on
the back page and you just see that
little s
that smug little i mean i got you huh
thanks for watching hit that like button
subscribe
subscribing is like voting it's
subscribing
is more important to voting than voting
don't bother
actually voting just subscribe and then
that saves a lot of time maybe i
shouldn't be telling people to
to not vote that's maybe not the best
i'm new
i'm new at this i don't know the what
what to say the way of kings
i'm just i'm gonna shut the [ __ ]